je présente chez nous la voiture
éoliennes la plus rapide de sa catégorie
et aucun qu'un aspect pratique pour la
vie de tous les jours avec un véhicule
éolien ça c'est aussi inconfortable ça
avance beaucoup des pots-de-vin puis ça
prend une équipe des singes et le
challenge d'ingénierie c'est de
fabriquer une voiture qui utilise un
vent de face comme seule énergie pour la
propulsion le vent va faire tourner les
pales de l'éolienne dupuis ensuite la
puissance est transmise de façon
mécanique aux roues arrière donc ya pas
de générateurs de batterie puis deux
moteurs électriques font avancer la
voiture
le record de 112 % qu'on a fait l'an
dernier cela veut juste dire qu'on était
plus vite que la vitesse de vent donc on
avait un vent de 18 km à ce moment là
puis on était genre à 18.2 ou 18 points
3 km contre le vent kankan en
compétition on arrive première place où
on bat deux équipes allemandes et équipe
des pays bas
c'est vraiment intéressant de savoir que
l'ingénierie canadienne est capable de
rivaliser avec les lieux l'ingénierie
allemande et l'ingénérie de travail par
tout le monde
du jour au lendemain qu'on va voir des
véhicules à propulsion éolienne sur nos
routes sûrement qu'on n'en verra jamais
le plus véhicules en premier c'est de
développer des technologies à la fine
pointe
c'est surtout tout ce qu'on développe en
ce moment c'est bon nécessairement
principe dans la vie de tous les jours
mais ça va former les ingénieurs dans
des énergies éoliennes une application
commerciale qu'on pourra voir avec notre
truc c
les éoliennes de petite échelle pour les
chalets par exemple l'éolienne qu'on a
développé un produit environ 6000 watts
une éolienne de taille similaire qui est
disponible commercialement va produire à
peu près 5 à 600 watts
ray allen est à peu près 10 fois plus
puissante risque est disponible sur le
marché
c'est certain que le véhicule éolien
fait rêver les gens donc c'est vraiment
comme ça qu'on arrive à promouvoir et le
fait que les énergies alternatives c'est
cool ça fonctionne c'est performant
[Musique]